okay we're going to wait 15 minutes and
then we will do a testing testing I'm
not sure if you guys noticed my my hair
color but you know what I'm the one
who's cooking what the he likes it or
not he still has to eat it we are the
three amigos all right you didn't do the
thumbnail picture here I did we're not
in the time the picture okay we could do
on do one now here you have to come in
closer ah sneaking holy cow Oh
hello everyone this is Nina today I'm
filming this cooking video by myself
Evan he's in the meeting right now he
has mastered my once a month on the
Thursday night so and I decided to do
the cooking video by myself today I'm
gonna make a breakfast meal it looks
like a key to actually I'm gonna put
some vegetable tomatoes pepper arugula
and some parsley in there what also you
only is a quite that's the main
ingredient for this quiche I will also
use salt paprika and pepper I'm gonna
put some dry basil in the quiche by the
way I grew these pesos on my balcony and
I dried them you're gonna have to grease
your muffin pan you can either use
cooking spray or you can use butter or
you can use oil we don't use a spray
cooking spray or butter at home so I'm
gonna use oil first I'm gonna use that
paper towel to grease the muffin pan I
made this dish when Evans parents and
his sister came over for brunch one day
and they liked it so I decided to show
you guys how I made it first of all
you're gonna put arugula into this
muffin pan you don't need a lot of the
arugula because you also won't put the
tomatoes and pepper in there so first
arugula just kind of fit up the muffin
pans just like this doesn't have to be
perfect next I'm gonna add some tomatoes
it's super easy for breakfast super
quick and then put some peppers in here
Evan doesn't really like pepper it
doesn't like cook pepper but you know
what I'm the one who's cooking whether
he likes it or not he still has to eat
it next I'm gonna put the dry basil I
love basil every time we eat when we eat
pasta whenever and I will you passed out
I always pursue a lot of Basil's in our
past out where spaghetti
then I'm gonna add some parsley you
don't have to cut it very fine for the
curse Lee because it's just gonna go
into your tummy anyways then of course
that white i bought these egg whites
from if you can see it's from costco
they have egg white cartons through the
muffin pan up with the egg white if you
don't mind Akio then your quiche you can
also add that go into your quiche as
well they will both taste yummy as you
can see filled up the egg whites almost
to the top and I spill the egg white ok
can you like this now now i'm gonna add
some salt just stash it in you don't
have to add a lot of salt because if
it's too salty you can really take their
way to the strong salt stays if it's
less you can always add it after and i'm
gonna add some the paprika's spice I
like paprika sometimes I put in my my
chicken and baked it it's tasty very
yummy last pepper I love the fresh
ground pepper it's mmm that's it now you
just have to put in the oven so before I
start the video i have already preheat
oven to 350 so it's ready i'm gonna put
the the Kishin there to pick for 15
minutes very importantly don't forget to
set your timer you don't want a burnt
quiche stir it ok we're gonna wait 50
minutes and then we will do a testing
testing with your tasting I'm not sure
if you guys notice my my hair color I
just diet two weeks ago you can see it's
purple I love it haven't I am I here for
so long I think the last time I dye my
hair that was 78 years ago the first
time when I diamond here actually
bleached a hole here diet and blonde and
then high end
Thank high like a red highlight I love
that but I don't do it I didn't I don't
do it anymore just really damaged my
sculpt anyway so once it's ready we'll
get back to to the quiche while I was
wedding waiting for the the first pan to
be ready I made another pan of the
quiche I was up off the egg white so I
beat up the whole egg I'm not sure if
you can see it's a little bit yellow but
what c1s is ready so I'm gonna put this
one in and then take the other one out
let's see if its good run eh its little
runny I'm gonna put it in for another
two to three minutes I don't know why
last time I think it for 15 minutes and
was perfect maybe cuz last night i use
only spinach and tomatoes this time at
more vegetable so [ __ ] okay so actually
let it bake for another five minutes so
total bake for 20 minutes at 350 degrees
so let's take it out so this is how it
looks like Devon's not here so I'm gonna
do the tasting by myself or maybe when
he gets me I'm gonna let him have some
and he will let you know what there's
good or not hmm hmm tell me I like it I
like it more this time than the last
time because there's more flavor the bay
so paprika flavor man I like it ok I'm
going to take everything out and put it
on the plate for Evan to try I just
thought of something while I was taking
out the vegetable quiche you could also
add bacon bits and this quiche if you
want some people might be vegetarian or
they don't want to have any meat so just
vegetable it's fine or you can add bacon
bits whatever you guys want ok I'm going
to leave these for Evan to try and
no we will record how he likes to take
the dish we are the three amigos all
right we just finished the meeting ready
to know we have guests coming it's 11 at
night almost here we gotta get these
guys home where we invited know they
make crime scene Roger okay you know
very smelled it from the streets when I
come up yeah it was i was waiting for
having to try to kiss I noticed there
are different colors I'm trying to
understand okay the reason why they're
two different color because I ran out of
egg whites cuz i buy only equi for this
keith thing yeah so I ran up equi so I
just beat a few eggs with that you in
any way this this is a quite big the
yellow one it's the whole egg okay okay
what where's the fork you know force
come to let is made her feel your
fingers you go after you I'm gonna try
that the whole agron are we gonna choose
choose yeah we just had all that sushi
man it's good stop that is really good
you want it or let it cook for our next
master India we does be sushi liquidy
just very good okay you guys like yeah
yay time or is that okay I take you home
hey well no I'm think I'm gonna take one
more try one home one ha okay that's
what miracles take them home are you
tomorrow anyway thank you guys for
watching continue to believe nice what's
your own worried oh whatever your one
more days and we'll see you soon season
and we gotta link out happy with work or
calm last minute training CA go check
them out night every night this is gonna
be a morning video though yeah good
morning honey continue to believe yeah I
do believe guys continue to body Chris
you're so late on that one we are doing
thank you guys for watching continue to
believe Chris we're still late on that
thank you guys for watching Candida to
believe okay